bonjour monsieur débute donc je le fais
dans steam le schmiblick est ce que le
fli du bic
exit y exécuter existait-il sur les
avions avant 1925
monsieur c'était à préciser que à oui
effectivement j'ai dit tout à l'heure ne
date pas 1916 alors vous allez un peu
progressé dans le temps alors disons
qu'en 1925 n'ont pas non plus vous avez
fait avancer un peu d'eau des finissants
sont tous nos dates
merci monsieur guy lux bonjour bonsoir
est ce que le smig bic et se tire à côté
de l'appareil se tient à côté de
l'appareil
oui est-ce que la marée il est le quel
appareil parler ou d'aviation revenir
donc se tient à côté de l'appareil
et alors vous avez ajouté quoi madame
est-ce que c'est bascule un as et
d'autres choses il faudrait choisir là
est ce que vous me posez la question est
ce que ça se tient à côté de l'appareil
ou est-ce que c'est masculin choisi ce
matin la skull 1 je préfère vous
choisissiez ça parce que la première qui
est la première des questions elle
n'avait pas d'intérêt
alors nous regardons puisque vous savez
que c'est un nom qui comporte plusieurs
mots effectivement on pourrait on
pourrait non le maire et qui ment
pourrait dire non